Останніми днями соцмережами активно поширюються ланцюгові розсилки
із неправдивими фактами або порадами на тему коронавірусу.
DW перевірила найпоширеніші фейки та міфи довкола пандемії.
Ось наша добірка:
Один з поширених фейків посилається на медиків університетської клініки Відня,
які начебто дослідили, що протизапальний препарат ібупрофен
погіршує перебіг коронавірусного запалення легенів.
Медуніверситет Відня категорично спростував це як дезінформацію.
Коронавірус передається повітряно-крапельним та контактним шляхом.
Однак клінічні дослідження у Німеччині не підтвердили,
що саме по собі носіння захисних масок захищає організм від китайського вірусу.
Звичайні маски допомагають радше не заразити інших,
і то лише протягом короткого часу.
Ефективніший захист - частіше й ретельніше мити руки, пояснює ВООЗ.
ВООЗ заперечила і це твердження.
Адже організм людини має температуру 36-37 градусів
- і тим не менше вірус почувається чудово в таких умовах.
Поради на кшталт поїхати в теплі країни, пити гарячі напої чи приймати гарячу ванну
не допомагають від коронавірусу, стверджує ВООЗ.
За даними німецького Інституту Роберта Коха, інкубаційний період
- тобто час від зараження до початку хвороби - в середньому становить 5-6 днів,
в окремих випадках до двох тижнів.
Водночас Інститут Джонса Хопкінса у США повідомляє,
що на 10 тисяч "коронавірусних" пацієнтів лише у ста одного
симптоми зберігалися після 14-денного карантину.
Більшість тих, хто заразився коронавірусом, одужують самі без медичної допомоги.
У 80% випадків хвороба протікає легко.
Тоді госпіталізація скоріш за все не потрібна.
Вірус більше нагадує звичайну застуду, ніж смертельну хворобу.
Симптоми - втома, підвищена температура, сухий кашель.
Навіть за складнішого перебігу хвороби більшість випадків - не летальні.
Відсоток смертності від вірусу науковці ще до кінця не встановили.
За деякими даними, він становить близько 3%.
Але багато експертів підкреслюють, що поки не всі дані вивчені.
Справжній рівень смертності може бути нижчим за 1%.
Раніше його оцінювали у 5%.
Група ризику - особи літнього віку та ті, хто має інші складні хронічні захворювання.
ВООЗ не має жодних підтверджень ефективності використання
часнику, цибулі й алкоголю як засобів профілактики.
Засоби на базі етилового спирту й хлору справді вбивають вірус
- але лише на поверхнях, а не в організмі!
Щодо часнику, то українські мережі облетіло це фейкове відео:
"Це інформація для всіх.
Найнадійніший засіб від коронавірусу – це часник".
Відомий російський медик Леонід Рошаль від порад про часник,
які даються начебто його голосом, дистанціювався.
На даний момент ані вакцини, ані ліків від SARS-nCoV-2 ще немає.
Перші випробування експериментальних препаратів для лікування коронавірусного запалення легенів
у Німеччині заплановані на квітень.
Пошук вакцини - питання багатьох місяців, якщо не років.
Поки пацієнтів з коронавірусом лікують так само, як і хворих на грип.
Відповідно пропозиції ліків та вакцин від коронавірусу в інтернеті - шахрайство.
Поки наукових підтверджень того, що домашні тварини,
наприклад, кішки або собаки, можуть інфікувати своїх господарів, немає.
Водночас науковці продовжують перевіряти таку можливість.
Люди не ризикують захворіти, торкаючись посилок.
Коронавірус не живе довго на конвертах або пакунках.
Тож, шукайте інформацію та користуйтеся порадами з офіційних веб-сторінок компетентних інституцій,
приміром, Всесвітньої організації охорони здоров'я.
З'явилося чимало теорій змов про умисне створення коронавірусу
- як різновиду біологічної зброї.
Однак ще жодного разу подібні теорії не поширював хтось із поважних наукових закладів.
І хоча походження вірусу досі однозначно не встановлено,
більшість світових фахівців схиляються до теорії, що вірус перейшов до людини від диких тварин.
Вважається, що подібним чином з'явилися також віруси Ебола та SARS.